all right center thanks for talking want
to talk about Ebola which of course is
the big story for the country right now
you've said the president has shown
lettuce down a road and failed to show
leadership specifically what has he done
or not done that you think it's not
young leadership I think from the very
beginning they haven't been completely
forthright with us they've so wanted to
downplay this that they really I don't
think have been very accurate in their
description of the disease for example
they say don't worry it's only mixture
of bodily fluids to direct contact so
what are you thinking I'm thinking like
age you don't get aids at a cocktail
party so my level of alarm goes down and
if I'm treating somebody or looking at
them around I'm thinking oh no it's like
AIDS I'm not going to get it but it
really isn't like aids and then they'll
say in a little lower voice oh but a
direct contact can be three feet from
somebody but if you ask any American on
the street do you think direct contact
is standing three feet from somebody I
don't think that was but they just
weren't you know that because there's so
much one to downplay that we were in
charge we know everything about this I
think they made mistakes and not really
being accurate about talking about the
disease use the phrase at least once
politically correct to describe what's
that mean in the context of how they've
done with it not sure what it means
because I'm not sure who they're being
politically correct to other than that
they don't want her anybody's feel what
made you use the phrase what action
because I think they're making it's an
irrational desire to be conventional and
not to make a you know sort of towards
the middle of things without saying
something that's bold that people might
object to and that's kind of political
correctness and we're up here
campaigning for Scott Brown and you've
done lots with other candidates I know
what you think Republicans have going
for you said when did your back earlier
today what are the Democrats have going
for them in the mid terms that are
keeping some of these races closer than
some suspect that they would be still
the biggest obstacle we have as
Republicans as demographics we need to
do better with african-americans
Hispanics Asian American that's a factor
in this election it's a factor in every
election in congressional races not so
much because they're drawn you know for
the races in states and in national
elections the biggest obstacle
Republicans have to being the dominant
party and I think we can I think we can
win hands down on policy because frankly
things haven't gotten any better under
the Democrats are still massive
employment black unemployment two times
white unemployment I think that we can
win on the policy once we get in to
break down the demographic bears that
really we haven't done a very good job
with in the past all right you're on the
cover of Time magazine again not for the
first time the line says the most
interesting man in politics does that
mean you're more interesting than dick
Durbin Lamar Alexander you know they're
really fascinating guys so yeah both
actually I don't know how we got that I
don't know I did how do we look at that
picture like most people in the comfort
time to think do I look handsome do you
look handsome there I said you know
we've got my glasses I can't even tell
that job alright so we've joking before
about who's funniest in your family and
you said there's that Germanic blood
you're making a general statement about
Germans and humor yeah you hate to
criticize a whole ethnic group but I'm
part of it so maybe it's okay Germans
are fastidious and hard workers and they
build things you know but the other half
of my family is Welsh in English and
they so one grandparents were really
hard working and the other grandparents
were maybe more you know joking around
singing songs reciting poetry so I may I
got half of that then I gotta dilute it
again so I'm afraid I really don't have
a career and stand out there I've heard
you tell some jokes he told some jokes
today the college kids out here and but
your speech is a pretty serious pretty
intense speech is humor part of
communicating in politics for you or you
think that's not necessary yeah I think
a joke I if I can remember a joke or
come up with a new joke I usually like
to start with the choke I think humor is
a great way of engaging people in fact
our young people I hate to break this to
you and they don't watch any news
channels so we're familiar with that
zero my kids if they want news you're
going to get news they will send me a
YouTube clip of Jimmy Kimmel Jon Stewart
that's where they get their news is from
comedians and so we need some more
conservative comedians what's going to
take so you're thinking of running for
president you've been nicely open about
that is like unlike some folks you've
seen it up close because your dad's
running you were out on the trail for
him what's hard about running for
president you know the travel is really
can wear you down and wear you out I
think the fatigue on basically the
family and all of that and I think the
breakdown between legit
reporters and everybody else has got a
website has made it so hard that there's
so many people asking questions and many
of them really when I read a news report
now that I'm involved with a mic oh wow
that wasn't him did you see this guy's
it was an objective news report most
stuff all over the internet is all
opinion and it sells on TV too why does
that make it harder for Canada what
makes it harder because everywhere you
go it's in a you know you're you're not
getting questions from a reporter you're
getting questions from an editorialist
and that makes it more difficult and
then you read scandal everything becomes
a scandalous headline and most headlines
don't even represent what's in the body
of the material so so if you run you're
gonna get asked lots of questions your
student up presidential history you're
familiar with Roger muds question to ted
kennedy yeah why are you running yes I
why do you want to press so I'm great
Jason was president dad was but you know
I'll be best so here's your chance
answer the Roger my question assuming
you did run why do you want to be
President because I'm truly concerned
about our country I think an 18
trillion-dollar debt is truly a danger
not destroy kids and grandkids but
actually to our kids now trying to find
jobs and then I don't think that the
demise of a country is always gradual I
think there is a possibility that you
can have a panic where an economy
unraveled why you 2008 why do I think I
can do it because I think I can bridge
the gap no other Republican has ever
bridged and that is a gap to attract
constituencies we haven't talked to an
80 it helps you get elected but why you
to solve the problems its president
because I think I can work with both
sides also I'm a person who believes
very very strongly in some ideas but
just turns out that some of those ideas
that we believe very strongly with
progressives as well I think also that
I'm a big believer that we try to tackle
too big of an issue in Washington so if
we had a hundred people in a room
senators or otherwise we tried to agree
on issues if the legislation had a
thousand pieces to it would never
anything done if it had one piece to it
we might find for 10 20 30 issues that
we could just pass almost by consensus
we have those in Congress now but the
leadership is so mal functional and
frankly it's Democrat leadership that we
don't get anything past I have a bill
that I co-sponsor with Harry Reid and I
can't get a vote on it Senator Paul
thanks you're nice
appreciate it thank you